so this is session 17 of classic metal
club i actually sent the wrong number to
scott so we're starting off right with
the topic i said this is session 16 but
we did session 16 last month and the
reason why it's such a
good segue is because today we're
talking about
parody in
heavy metal and it's it's a topic that
connects up with satire that connects up
with
the over-the-top nature of metal to
begin with and also the broader theme of
comedy but you know scott and i have
been kicking this idea around for a long
time is parody of metal also still
metal
i think the answer is mostly going to be
yes and it shows the
the what would you call it like you know
the fact that the genre itself can
expand so much the elasticity we could
say of of the genre right at a certain
point you can say about things well
that's not metal anymore or that's
that's too mean-spirited to really be
parody or things like that but uh
there's a lot of of scope and i think
that some of the parody bands
have certainly expanded
the range of metal and they've also
you know drawn
in some cases not just anger or ire from
uh metal performers but you know laughs
and appreciation as well
one of the things we're going to talk
about death clock and you know medic
apocalypse actually has a ton of metal
musicians as guest stars who came in and
gave their voices to it like scott ian
for example or steve vi or
there's like an entire list so um
interesting topic to to work with but we
should say well what is parody scott if
you had to like give a
thumbnail one-liner about what parody is
what would you say
i think in this case it's um uh taking
well it's kind of like when you go to
the carnival and somebody draws a
picture of you the character of you okay
you take some of the features that are
kind of um
on the line of being ridiculous and
expanding them big time so it's clearly
not
well
like maybe not
so you just take the stuff and make it
uh
uh ridicul ridiculous you push it into
the ridiculous okay and the ridiculous
means the laughable what what we can
uh make fun of what you know and people
can be making fun of somebody else or
they can be making fun of themselves
um
yeah parody i was thinking about this
before we started you can't just like
have some guy standing up and saying man
you suck that's not parody right that's
just criticism
there has to be some taking features
like you said and
going further and further with them
and that kind of brings up an
interesting idea off right off the bat
is metal by its very nature
in some sense
perotic
because it you know it it takes things
that can't really be
realized in in real life and
introduces them
and you know expands them think about
the gestures on stage you know bruce
dickinson talks about this how he you
know you have to make these very big
broad gestures
um it's not quite parody at that point
but it's certainly
it's certainly over the top right i'm
i'm wearing this you know motley crew
shout at the devil thing where um you
know they've they've got this clear look
of uh hairspray and makeup and
leather and all that stuff and you can
you can tell that they weren't all that
committed to it because almost
immediately after that
comes the next album where they don't
look like that at all you know
so what you know were they engaging in
kind of parody at the time
uh just oh go ahead oh sorry i was gonna
say um at the beginning of all of this
um i don't think they're engaged in
parodies so as far as the gestures uh
when we went to arena rock the idea was
to give the people in the back row their
money's worth yeah so if you're gonna
stand in one place and just kind of play
to the first ten rows
um but you know when you get the when
you got the vhs right and it's got
close-ups of these people doing this
stuff where they're trying to reach you
know the ten thousand people in the back
or whatever yeah sense that they adapted
the show
with the pyrotechnics and um
uh and then the outfits will you know
look at kiss uh
i remember as a young metal lover in
high school saying
i can't buy those clothes anywhere these
are you know these are super human
people like they're not you know now the
big disappointment is like people that
are playing metal look like they just
came out of a bar with you know j crew
clothes on and it's not really that
mystique so i don't think
you know it's easy to look back on it
um if you weren't there and go well
that's just ridiculous yeah yeah i think
at the time you know arena rock trying
to reach well a lot of them you know
were more than 10 000 20 000 people
selling out nights there wasn't twitter
you know all we had was the posters on
our wall and these people were bigger
than life not wearing the jeans that we
would our moms would buy us right
yeah yeah i mean we didn't have we i
mean there were music videos in uh
in this in the 70s and then mtv comes in
in 81
but you know
that was so curated you didn't have much
access we had you know
magazines like you know where i was we
basically only had hit parader and
circus we didn't have things like
carrang
um which would have been kind of nice to
get our hands on and that was it that
was the channels through which you would
you would get
uh exposure so it was
in some respects the music itself had to
be doing most of the work right
yes yep absolutely
yeah
um and the music uh i guess with the
parody of that um
is taking well you know how like in the
80s all the lyrics were kind of like you
know
um
[Music]
uh you know it's like slide it in and it
has white stick with the snake and you
know it's always like this kind of like
two steps away from what they're trying
to say the innuendo right
that's what i'm looking for and the
parody is skipping the innuendo and just
saying you know exactly what they're
you know trying to be suave and saying
that would be the the parody part of the
non-visual i think
yeah yeah that makes sense um so there
there's there's a lot of perotic
elements
to metal and then we actually do get
um
metal parodies
you know the big landmark would be of
course spinal tap and we're going to
talk about that in a bit but we you know
we can also talk about predecessors
you know frank zappa and the mothers of
invention they're not metal but they are
heavy and same with cheech and chong you
know um when they would have music on
their albums it was it was goofy songs
but it was it was pretty heavy stuff you
know
i'm forgetting the name of that one
but it has you know my mama talking to
me telling me how i ought to live and
then it's got that heavy riff oh eric is
that your ache in my eye yeah there you
go yeah
so you know there's there's that stuff
going on
um
i kind of think that you couldn't have
had
a spinal tap before the 80s because
metal is an identifiable genre but it's
but it's kind of it's it's confusing
about what counts as
metal it it was a little bit better
defined in the 80s than in the 70s and
it was often used as a term of uh abuse
or a probium you know
that that metal stuff is dying you know
being replaced by punk or being replaced
by disco or being you know and then
you've got the metal artist still still
going on and there are always
discussions about well who's metal who's
not is kiss heavy metal is ac dc heavy
metal um i remember a copy of uh circus
where like the headline was ac dc we're
not a heavy metal band so quick calling
us
um
but you know they're they're so there it
took a while before there could be
enough traction you could say
to really
parody things to make fun of things um
you know they're
i mean you could be making fun of black
sabbath say in 1975 but
i'm not sure that many people would be
laughing
as they would in 1983 you know
right well you know funny about that
with the spinal tap is i've seen a lot
of interviews with christopher guest
that he got the idea in 74 but it hadn't
he didn't talk about it he said he was
in a hotel
uh
lobby and this band showed up and i
don't know if he knew who the band was
but he protected their name okay
they're trying to check in the base and
the
the manager says to the bass player
where's your base and he does it in a
british accent right yeah he goes i
don't know
well where is it
maybe it's at the airport
and so he so christopher guest said he
just watched
this back and forth of this bass player
that had no idea where his base was the
manager getting like completely irate at
him
and he said he remembered that years
later i mean he always stuck with that
story about like you know the clueless
british metal guy
yeah i don't think anything you know it
was about 10 years before the movie came
out
so um
i guess the uh the cluelessness factor
existed but then all the rest of the
stuff like with the you know with the
worn out head that they were bringing on
the road and the little stonehenge and
you know i think all that stuff
eventually came we all thought it was
like taken from iron maiden but uh well
the stonehenge one was was taken from
black sabbath but it's a later black
sabbath after they've you know lost uh
uh osborne because they fired him and
then he's replaced by ronnie james dio
and then dio leaves
starts his own solo career and then they
have ian gillen
and they had well they had a song called
stonehenge on that album born again 1983
and and and apparently the you know the
the joke is
that
um
the dimensions were wrong but in the the
other direction it wasn't too small they
were too big and then they're like how
are we going to take these things on the
road and the people were just dwarfed by
the the massive fake stones so yeah
you know
to come before we talk about spinal tap
itself there's a few other things that i
i
wanted to
throw out there um you know if we think
about one of them is
if we think about the the glam and
makeup and stuff like that
so yeah kiss was already kind of perotic
um in what they're doing it's not like
they're like you need to take this this
you know our personas seriously right
there's ace the space man over there
don't joke about him you know and then
you know look at the demon be scared you
know or something like that they're just
coming out and they've got these
personas
and you know they're willing to do
things like be in a live-action movie
uh about a rollercoaster park and stuff
like that so that's kind of silly right
they admitted it they said they were fed
lines at the time there was no real
script right oh really that was like
ad-libbed that's awesome
they just said we would show up and they
would tell us what to say so somebody
had a general idea yeah but i mean
you know suddenly we get other bands
where they're really pushing the
envelope think about the plasmatics with
wendy oh william you know coming out on
stage dressed in duct tape and you know
chainsaws and stuff like that you got
wasp who's trying to you know a lot of
people thought wasp was basically a kiss
clone that was the accusation back in
the 80s you know rat was an aerosmith
clone uh boss was a kiss clone but but
they were they were doing their own
thing and they were incorporating all
these interesting things they actually
gave um motley crew some of their stage
stuff uh blackie lawless gave like
lighting himself on fire
to nikki six
um you know and and we have other
bands that are
essentially parotic and this is a little
bit later on you can think of man of war
um
i mean are they are they serious metal
yes they're so serious metal that
they're almost like a caricature of
metal you know there's that great song
all men play on 10.
[Laughter]
um gore people always bring up you know
well yeah i mean that's and that's you
know
if
i've never been to a gore show when my
brother was at some and clearly
it was just ridiculous like he said that
you know what's uh odorous
urungus right yeah yeah
he said there was this did they break
this big aerosol can on stage and it
said aids on it and he just sprayed the
crowd with it oh wow he said he just
said it was so ridiculous we were
laughing so hard and of course that
wasn't meant to be serious it was
supposed to be like you know um that's
just
that that's that that doesn't even make
sense to the point so um
and i think didn't you order august do
some interviews on like talk shows like
in character yes i mean i was gonna say
those guys really committed to the act
right to wear all that costume stuff and
then try to play instruments
i know i mean it's one thing to put on
like the kiss makeup that's already a
lot you know and try to walk her out of
those platform boots um right
oh god yeah but man i would i would
agree man of war is kind of a um i
always thought of them as kind of like a
uh kind of
well
metal with a sense of humor i don't know
if they were making a parody of other
people
you know that's that's the distinction
between like spinal tap and say gore
gore wasn't thinking of anybody in
particular they were just being funny
and ridiculous yeah sort of like um
we're going to talk about them later
um max sabbath right so
so and this is here we're talking about
a contemporary band
max sabbath does
black sabbath-esque songs essentially
just taking doing the weird al yankovic
kind of thing where you're
taking the lyrics and you're changing
them up a bit and you're basically
keeping most of the riff so it's
identifiable
and they're dressed like
mcdonald's characters so you've you've
got i mean let's let's jump hamburger
yeah well the
hamburglar is guitarist right um yeah uh
cat burglar is is the the name for that
and then you have um
ronald osborne
supposed to be ozzy osbourne slayer
mccheese who is the guitar player uh
that's supposed to be tony oh me right
mayor mccheese is the the copy of that
and then grimalis aka i can't believe
it's not butler obviously the bassist
right play playing geezer butler but and
the guy's in a uh grimace suit you know
it's again it's one thing to put like
clown makeup on or to put like a mask on
but to dress up like grimace and and
play that's uh really quite something oh
they took sabbath songs and replaced
them with
uh lyrics about the mcdonald's
it's all food themed yes
that is the one unifying bit of that um
so yeah that's that's uh you know pretty
crazy but you know
the man war thing so are they
deliberately being perotic in a way of
the genre and pushing it further so that
it becomes
kind of ridiculous or are they taking
themselves seriously and then becoming
funny as a result i'll bring up another
band that's kind of in that that thing
cauldron
so cauldron you know they they rock
they've got some pretty good um songs
and stuff like that but you look at some
of the um
lyrics
and so they have this this album 2009
chained to the night and it's of course
n-i-t-e so already there you're kind of
on guard and they've got a song called
chained up in chains
so you've got this duplication taking
place it's not like you know unchain my
heart or something like that you know
take these chains off you know off of
judas priests um
uh
um screaming for vengeance album where
it's kind of a i mean if you're going to
criticize that for anything maybe it's
too schmaltzy you know in terms of the
lyrics take these chains off of my heart
you know uh well this is chained up in
chains so
just by doing that it it's starting to
become whether they intend it to or not
i think perotic
well it's like the the spinal tap song
tonight we're gonna rock it tonight
yeah
yeah and so maybe maybe that's a a
hallmark the
taking the lyrics or taking the titles
and and steering them in in a direction
that tells us the listeners hey this is
kind of kind of goofy stuff right
yeah exactly i would say that like man
of war
they
to me they teeter on being serious
um
but maybe a little ridiculous gore is
certainly not so gore is certainly out
you know be silly and you know um when
my brother saw him they just had all
these antics that just were just so
ridiculous
that they were funny because they didn't
even make sense it's like who would do
that or who would think of that it's
like they're in a tour bus
it's like you know with the giant can of
aids um
that reminds me
of um you know the sergeant d and the
sod stormtroopers of death
album right the stuff that they were
singing
even then was very very politically
uncorrect and
um it wasn't borderline offensive it was
deliberately offensive
and you know
you could so for example speak english
or die right um
that that's there's a lot of ethnic
stereotypes in there um
if you look at it as
comedic
then you might give them a pass right
and there might even be people who are
like hey i'm you know i i work in a
convenience store i find this thing
funny myself
um if you take it as seriously then it's
very very offensive right
and it's it's interesting because um
where do you draw the line this is a big
debate that's going on these days in
terms of comedians and
and joking around and um i think the
same sort of
issues arise for
for metal parody bands
right
well yeah i mean
i mean yes i mean steel panther has some
pretty
offensive lyrics yeah yeah um
and
i mean i'm sure they offend people
um but i i think you know where what are
you coming from a place of
um
are you
[Music]
are you are you poking fun at yourself
like this kind of person should be
laughed at that's talking like this or
are you making a claim
um you know when you say this do you you
know what's the ballad that speaking of
uh
taking the innuendos out uh steel
panther has that ballot it's it's just
all about doing these you know
um
pretty awful things to uh his date
yeah he wants to do it so
i mean we would hear that as okay we
should
we're supposed to be laughing at you for
being such an idiot or or we're laughing
at it because you've taken the innuendo
out of metal and so now it's not like
koi at all it's just this is what they
actually mean to say half the time
um
that's a good point you know could some
of this stuff have existed these days
well i mean it it some of it i think
could um it depends on where it's going
to be like you know you can create a
youtube video
and and do more or less anything that
you want especially if you keep yourself
anonymous
um yeah one of the one of the bands that
we're going to look at in just a bit
is um
well i mean max sabbath kept themselves
anonymous but i also think you know
which taint is is a good example
they're not anonymous actually because
but they they because they do have
personas but there's you know they're
they're in masks all the time
uh and the stuff that they do is really
over the top
so so we'll definitely talk about that
now mark asks what my question these
situations is what's the punch line i
like speak english or die precisely
because i know people who think like
that and they're morons so yeah the
parodying could be i mean so there could
be three things right scott talked about
making fun of yourself
um or making fun of somebody else you
know like punching down but it could
also be making fun of the you know the
yahoos
whatever we're going to call them the
you know the the dorks the rednecks the
you know
people that actually believe it yeah
yeah um
so i there so there's three
possibilities there at least and i mean
there might be other things that people
are making fun of as well
um
i mean with the max sabbath thing i
think just by stepping out they're
already making fun of mcdonald's right
um
which is you know massive corporation so
uh
it's not like it's not like they're
gonna cut into mcdonald's profits and
steal money out of the mouths of
mcdonald's employees or something like
that well they might help it they might
be a walking advertisement in some way
you know
but i think to i think think to
what
the extent expand on what mark's saying
it's like a lot like what happened in
the 80s what we saw is we saw
um remember like the hearings that we we
always talk about
uh should we put right
and the problem with the tip or gore
panel is they
um you know they had john denver in
there for example rocky mountain high
it's got to be about drugs right you
know that's it they were taking
everything seriously and in the worst
light possible i mean to go after john
denver you know he was pretty tame right
who had to explain
you know i think every child should have
you know this high you get from being in
the mountains in the fresh air of
colorado and
and but you know what what i think
happened there and what happens a lot is
people don't know the author yeah they
don't read the full content or they
misinterpret it so that's laziness so
if you know it's kind of like if you
listen to the chorus of a song and go
well that's offensive these people are
terrible well that's lazy because you
know let's say somebody took um
uh steel panther seriously and said well
these people need to be taken wait a
minute you don't know the the author or
the source there this is a parody band
this is this is making fun of
i mean i kind of think you can take any
metal lyrics probably and you can find
some way to be offended by them so think
about like motley crue too young to fall
in love yeah who are you to say that
somebody's too young to fall in love
where is the age cut off is it 13 is it
11 is it 18 you know
who are you to dictate this i mean
that's a you know uh just an
off-the-cuff kind of thing but there's
probably some jackass out there who has
oh yeah looked at it and he's like well
i'm offended by that you know or think
about iron maiden's invaders right a
song off of the number of the beast
album that sometimes people get you know
they get down on they're like that's a
bad song you know i actually think it's
a good song but if if there's any song
on that album that gets attacked it's
invaders now somebody else could read it
they could be like
you know this is terrible you know the
saxons should be welcoming the vikings
why are they why are they attacking them
you know or why why in the flight of
icarus did he have to fly so close to
the sun you know you're treating icarus
as if he's a stupid guy you know well
that's
well you know this this is where we come
with comedians uh you know just to step
out of it and we're seeing an instagram
with visual art
where
we you know we're losing the you know
not not that we need to call uh
you know all the lyrics art but you know
um
the expression of of an artist to
sing about whatever and then to say well
you know this this isn't going to be
acceptable
i guess it's always been that way you
know when the impressionists came out
they were they were shut up um so
yeah it's kind of um
we're in a different stage of it now i
guess um and comedians are suffering i
guess um
but uh yeah i mean it's it's you're
right i mean you could really choose to
be offended and you know some people
will
uh they have enough time on their hands
to spend hours and hours a week to try
to go after these people
um
yeah i mean we could probably i mean
that's a whole other topic that we could
delve into a lot but i do want to
mark asks how would you distinguish
parody from satire and i'm not sure that
i would
it's it seems to me like they're both
doing the same kind of thing
maybe satire could be more fully
developed like you know when we talk
about so a spinal tap
is a satirical
as well as perotic movie and i mean it's
a it's a big big production right
but if again if we want to think about
big productions
metapocalypse
season after season
goes much further than say spinal tap
does
i think parody is involved but maybe you
have to have a certain amount of um
structure to have a satire
well a parody would be remember the show
aqua team hunger force yeah i was
actually i was i've been re-watching
that lately so they had like um
they had danzig on there they had um
zach
zack wilde yeah and each time carl's
involved in making fun of them yeah you
know he's always making like you know
he's
carl's the fat slob that lives next door
and um
what happened when uh
when um
oh ted nugent shows up he's like oh let
me go get my cat scratch fever loincloth
and he comes he comes back and you know
and then he just you know he shoots carl
with an arrow and he's like well this is
the best day of my life i got shot by
you know
so
and you know uh
you know and danzig comes in and he
wants this house because there's blood
flowing on the walls yeah yeah
so i mean that would be kind of a parody
to have a guest to make fun of
themselves on there all the time one of
the best parts of that uh is when shake
is um
he comes up with a
rip-off of the scorpion's big city
nights that he calls bruschetta knights
so there's already like a a double thing
there because bruschetta could be like
red barchetta right yeah and he's
brought up rush before and then shake
gets sued by the scorpions
and he's he says i'm gonna go to court
and frylock is like you're not gonna
wear that are you and he's like yeah i
am and he's got this the forks over his
eyes from the
blackout album
yeah and uh yeah that's just amazing
there's um what's the one where he's
like oh i'm gonna go get my screaming
for vengeance shirt you know
well carl yeah i mean carl carl
there's a lot of name dropping
of metal bands throughout the entire
thing and carl talks about the shows
that he's been to
and um there's even one where there's
like this imaginary metal land and carl
tells the story about how he did this
total badassery you know fighting off
these three demons and it turns out that
the shirt itself um you're gonna be the
gorn lord right uh the shirt itself uh
makes you like hallucinate and have
these terrible dreams and it's digging
itself into like you're
ultimately into your brain yeah and
shake um ends up trying to shake is kind
of a poser type for anybody who doesn't
know
and he's trying to do it but he doesn't
have the badassery that that carl does
and so he uh winds up getting raped by a
giant cthulhu-like octopus um that's
right
coming back to the thing that mark was
saying i've heard it said parody is
making fun of something you like a show
of affectional satire is making fun of
something you don't like so critique
i i don't know i mean i think that that
some people maybe stipulate the
difference between them that way but
you could i mean i think you could have
mean-spirited parody
uh just as much as you could have
uh you know loving satire i don't know
that the
that the dividing line comes down that
way
well it's interesting you know not sorry
to interrupt but no
my brother and i went to see mystery
science theater um if you've ever seen
that it's it's the the guy gets shot
into space yeah he builds two robots and
they just wisecrack over old terrible
movies and so my brother and i went to
see them do it live a couple years ago
and they did a q a after okay
and my brother asked
you know you make fun of these movies
and you know uh all this stuff do you
like these movies do you like the movies
from this era and they're like very much
they're like you know there's a certain
thing and they they went on and on about
the sentiment of the movies and all this
stuff and so they're clearly cracking
or making fun of these movies or the
characters or the writing yeah yeah but
in the end it's kind of like well we
actually love this genre or you know it
kind of it reminds me of something that
was a sticking point in um the
relationship between me and my my wife
who loves like a vast variety of music
i'm fortunate that she likes metal
because we get to go to metal shows
together but but her her tastes are much
more
uh
eclectic and catholic than than mine
and
she would hear me like you know i just
kind of
randomly will will
do things that are kind of parody
of of uh music and i've been doing this
and so is my my sister and so did me and
my friends since we were kids you know
and i think she got the idea
that
i was only doing this with um
music that i didn't like
so something would come on
and you know i would i would change the
lyrics up so it becomes kind of you know
silly or raunchy or something like that
or i would i would uh whistle the line
but kind of get it off you know wrong
the main riff or something
and it really uh hurt her feelings you
know she felt like i was denigrating her
music
until she finally realized that i would
do that with metal stuff as well you
know
so
it you know it's it's almost like a tick
on my part it's not something i often
think it's not something i devote any
thought to like how can i take this song
and you know do the weird el yankovic
thing to it you know i'm not doing that
i'm just kind of bsing around with it
in a semi-creative not particularly
intelligent way
and you know i'll make fun of judah's
priest or the scorpions or you know uh
ufo or pick whoever you like and then
once she realized that it didn't bother
her anymore i mean it still bothered her
that i would do it maybe too much
uh
that's the same reason exactly yeah yeah
and so i think this motivation thing
that mark is bringing up i don't think
it helps us divide parity from satire
but i think it is a really important
distinction
whether it's being done in kind of a
light-hearted you know or poking fun
kind of way or whether it's whether it's
mean-spirited like you're saying look
how much this sucks we're going to show
you that this this band is is crap you
know so i mean take think before for a
case study um
a band that a lot of people make fun of
for only knowing three chords is ac dc
and obviously they know more than three
chords but i don't know that there's
actually more than six different chords
in their their albums you know um
because you know they stick basically to
some pretty standard progressions you
know they're not merciful fate
right
right or prong or you know some some you
know much more advanced band um
now if we wanted to make fun of acdc
there's a lot of ways we could go about
it so you know think about
recent things that have happened uh
brian johnson having to retire for a
while because of vocal issues um
malcolm young dying right
we could um parody that in ways that are
really really mean-spirited you know
like we could make up some cartoon in
which angus young
um
beams his brother over the head with
with a guitar or something like that
malcolm young dies as a result that
would be pretty mean-spirited you know
yeah um
and uh and you know we could we could
also take the same things i think
and
um treat them in more lighthearted ways
you know you know brian johnson blew out
his vocal cords
uh and then we could like make some
cartoon where he has to get like an
artificial you know voice box and it
rocks even more and then we have carl
blutowski there going yeah
[Laughter]
there's different ways we could take the
same basic idea and and change it up
depending on what our motivation is you
know
um
i just want to um chime in with the
distinction chris is bringing up
something too
um there are certain people that make
satire of bands we love and we love it
because
they clearly are in the know like um
that guy that wrote that funny article
in i think was it the onion it's and it
had this um
kind of like uh
fat doughy guy like in his mom's house
and he goes i learned all of my history
from iron maiden
and so in it it had all these like
extreme total examples like you know
yeah i didn't know that man and dinosaur
were on the pla planets together we
played it together but you could tell
that the person that wrote it
is is in the know because they are they
they put this together like we would and
they wrote something for people like him
yeah or so that we can laugh at and i
figure if we're laughing at it
somebody's in the know with us and we
know they're not making fun of the band
we love but it is kind of funny
yeah that makes that makes a lot of
sense
um
there's one other thing before we get to
spinal tap that i wanted to bring up
there's you know there's a lot of other
tv appearances and skits and sketches i
mean you brought up aqua teen hunger
force with one of the super metal fans
carl blutowski
the beavis and butthead show right
beavers and butthead are essentially
metalheads who are are listening to
other stuff and then sometimes making
fun of it and they're making fun of the
metal stuff too
sometimes sometimes deliberately
targeting it and sometimes just being
stupid and asking questions to show they
don't understand what a song is about
you know that's true
and you know that's a really good one
because
you know the
the big thing with that was you know you
know winger was really upset
you know because the dorky kid wears a
shirt and i said well at the same time
the stupid kids are wearing the ac dc
and metallica shirts you know so i mean
um
uh right and they would you know uh
i always thought that was a cop out of
the show where they would do the videos
i just figured they didn't want to
you know my judge didn't want to write
20 minutes of
um
you know uh dialogue and yeah plot and
stuff like that ninety percent of what
they see in the videos doesn't make any
sense and it's just kind of stupid it's
kind of like you get a five-minute show
and then 15 minutes and i'm going uh
this sucks you know yeah um i mean when
they're in school or when they're like
at the store or trying to cut lawns or
stuff like that you could you get you
see how stupid these guys are and you
you know i mean scott and i i think knew
a lot of guys like that you know
yeah oh yeah well that was
that
talk about parody i mean i think beavis
and butthead were it was like uh
uh an extreme of some like uh
of the characteristics of people that we
knew
uh yeah high school for sure it's kind
of like well this is about two two or
three notches above what the people we
knew were but we we see what this is you
know but especially that they get away
with stuff it's kind of like mr magu
right where you know it ends up working
out for them somehow like they do these
horrible things and that's true mark
says a lot of metalheads don't have much
besides metal in their heads yeah i mean
and so like growing up in the 80s right
as scott and i did in middle america
where being
into metal um and then like you know
dressing in certain ways
um
talking in certain ways it was it was
part of i i hesitate to call it a
lifestyle because it wasn't that much
of a lifestyle you could say
um for some people but it was something
that people were committed to just like
they were committed to other kinds of
music as well right
and um beavis and butthead you know they
they exemplify
a certain kind of metalhead who's going
nowhere after school they're going to be
working at the car wash
they'll probably end up having you know
they'll get somebody pregnant
who's uh
equally without prospects they'll have
you know a miserable life with a bunch
of kids together and then you know when
they're they go to the class reunion for
you know the 20 year you'll be like wow
uh you're still wearing that same shirt
it just doesn't cover your belly now you
know or something like that so
um
there are some other tv things that i
thought we could talk about
you know scott in the past you brought
up that french and saunders uh skit with
the court and the tabs and so that had
lemmy in it it had gary moore in it
they're they're willing to joke about
their lack of musical
yeah david gilmour uh yeah
and um who else was in that uh
mark knopfler or as he says mark
canopler
and the basic the basic gag for those
who haven't seen it is
these musicians these extremely talented
musicians are called upon to play in a
court of law and they go and they're
supposed to look at the sheet music and
they're like i i i can't play this it
doesn't have the little lines for me and
what what are we talking about there
guitar bass tablature you know so the
joke is that these musicians can't
actually read music well
actually the joke is the father bought a
book called so-and-so's easy all right
so he takes he takes the writer of the
book to court and says look even the
original artist can't play what you
wrote
and so um i love it with lemmy uh he
they all come and play in their main
riff right and they sound great and then
it's like okay now with the music
and uh and you know that they're they're
they're hesitant you know it's like i
love levy he goes well i can't why well
stuck doesn't have the picture you know
he wants to know that they need the
pictures of where to put their finger
right right yeah
now there's also an snl skit called
kitty metal
um which has like it makes up like a
whole album and there's a kid and he's
like his mom is like do you want to read
a book or do you want to listen to your
new album and he's like i'll listen to
my new album and then suddenly
axel and slash played by adam sandler
and kiefer sutherland are there and
there's like smoke and they're they're
playing kitty socks
but in a metal way you know so that's
you know that's kind of poking fun at uh
that era of metal but i think that the
like
probably the best the the prototypical
let's make fun of metal
skit on tv is um the cowbell skin from
snl right with christopher walken
yeah it's blue oyster cult and then it's
will ferrell as you know
a belly shirt and he's the cowbell
player and this is where that that whole
like meme of you know needs more cowbell
comes from because christopher walken
who
is billing himself as bruce dickinson
music producer
first dickens of the the singer of iron
maiden who who it wasn't a music
producer at that time right um is being
played by christopher walken who doesn't
look like him at all just says that he's
bruce dickinson he keeps on saying i
think the track needs more cowbell for
um don't fear the reaper right right and
it gets more and more crazy as time goes
on until he's got that line i got a
fever and a fever for more cowbell
the only cure is that's right yeah yeah
well
um
you know it's funny because
you know
the genius part of that skit is the
original version has this cowbell in it
and we all knew that yeah and we you
know he stopped and asked what the heck
who made that decision who produced that
track you know
and um
yeah and of course the guys at boc still
get asked about that to the day
apparently you know um i saw them soon
after the skit came out and um they just
they got like about 30 people from the
audience and gave them cowbells to come
on stage during that really
it was a mess but they certainly cashed
in
so that's i mean that's a good way of
responding to
parody right you could get really sour
and be like who are they to make fun of
us you know we're serious musicians
but you could also like embrace it i
think
i guess eric bloom was they they kept
asking what was your response because
well i i think it's great now because at
the time i was just watching
the show
and all of a sudden it said bloister
called behind the music and he said i i
said oh no we're in for it now like he
didn't even know it was going to air
wow he said he saw it when it aired and
um at first he i i he didn't say he was
upset he didn't think it was funny
though okay because gene the cowbell
player is eric bloom they you know he
was dressed as eric bloom okay with the
same shades and everything so
eric bloom was the character of the
cowbell player
he's being targeted then singled out
um but
buck you know
black always just thought it was cool he
goes hey you know um
i guess they get a million reaper gets a
million plays on spotify
a month now wow
and uh you know it's like it's
what i mean that's a separate episode uh
for us but um what pop culture could do
to bring a band like journey when you
know don't stop believing it the end of
the sopranos
right yeah so um so sometimes parody
could bring something i guess in this
case
you know there could be a huge benefit
to a revival of a band
as long as the bands
like you said as long as they're willing
to go along with a joke
yeah and as long as they're in a
position to be able to capitalize on it
you know
like if you had a band that had broken
up already and you know some of the
musicians are dead or something
and then you find a good way to like
make fun of it there's not much
you know like for example
i'm not sure how you would do this
because i don't have any thoughts in my
head about this but if you were going to
parody
um motorhead right so all three original
members are gone um
and i mean you could say well there's
you know virtual still out there and all
that but you know they've decided not to
try to do the
morbid let's tour as as a band that
doesn't have any of its members left
anymore i mean lemmy is is a funny guy
right you listen to interviews he's
cracking jokes all the time and making
observations that are kind of sardonic
and it would be very easy to
to dress up like him
and you know put like a you know big
mole on your face and stuff like that
and take the gravelly voice
if you did that it's not like you're
gonna
you're gonna help him out in any way
whereas like you you know pointed out
the snl skit can get people listening to
uh blue easter cult because they're
still around and and you know yeah
yeah
um
well you know i
i do think uh in the case of motorhead
in the era we're in
a tribute band could cash in on that and
further the parity
let's say um you know it might be
motorhead but based off of the skit
what is what the fans really want to
hear because the skit was so wildly
popular you can cash in
on on the skit itself like if there's a
bloister called tribute band i'd be
shocked if they didn't do something
about the cowbell yeah that's that's
that's true that makes a lot of sense um
yeah you know
this is a little bit off topic but
there are a lot of
all-female tribute bands
and i think one of the big challenges
with that in addition to
to trying to getting the guitar right i
don't think that's that difficult right
the drums the bass but getting the
vocals right not for somebody like
you know somebody who sings high anyway
but trying to imitate lemmy you know i
think that could be quite difficult
and
um you know trying to have the same sort
of stage presence
um
that might i mean is that it's not
really in the realm of parody is it
though it's um well it's it's pushing an
envelope taking a certain style
at visual as well as um musical and then
putting it into a different framework
i mean um
not that i agree with it but a lot of
people would call it a gimmick
okay i don't necessarily agree with that
one of my friends was in a band called
blonde jovi they're all blonde girls and
bon jovi actually got litigious with
them
and they got here's the funny thing bon
jovi got upset well their legal team
and all of a sudden they found their
shows packed but blonde jovi did and
they were all of a sudden being
interviewed everywhere and you know they
just had to change it because they said
i think that
they read it on the air or something
that says we as we don't have a problem
with the word blonde we do have the
problem with the word jovi oh okay just
you know and um
so you know to go after a cover band
but like you know the iron maidens right
or um judas priestess
belts for ac dc you know zeppelin yeah
um uh zaparella my friend
my friend gretchen's the guitarist and
zaparella and you know i think it's cool
because
people will call it a gimmick
um but i think it's an opportunity for
women to do tribute bands of bands they
love yeah um you're right for the low
growly voice you know it would be a
little more difficult to find somebody
to fit the bill
um you know it's not hard to find a
great female
armor or um there's no shortage uh yeah
yeah i think you know yeah in this case
of lemmy um you might have to go to the
you know um what is
it uh
what's that metal band and that that
petite blonde has the most
gravelly metal scream voice is it um
mark do you know who i'm talking about
uh i want to say the word angels in it
okay enemy is it arch enemy
maybe argentina
yeah okay
um
yeah that that actually reminds me of
one other tv thing that i i i had
forgotten about but i want to bring up
betty white
uh
she on snl years and years ago
she um
she did like a um
a version of
what is it from the golden girls uh
thank you for being a friend right the
the snl people all got together and they
did this nice cutesy you know like in
black and white oh thank you for being a
friend and then betty white is sitting
there and she's like oh that's very nice
thanks for doing that
and then she says i prefer my version
better
she pulls out a black ski mask and she
gets up and then she starts doing like a
metal growling you know thank you for
being a friend and it gets very frenetic
and people start punching each other and
stuff like that
i miss that
it's you you could you could find it i
don't know if it's there you can easily
google it i don't know if it's actually
on youtube but there's other ways to get
to it
all right well let's talk about the the
um er parody
that really i think gets things going
spinal tap right
very well thought out like you said
christopher guest had been thinking
about this for for quite a while
um we you know we kind of think about
them as the or as the origin of metal
parody
and
they do go back to the 70s there's a
sketch in the tv show featuring the band
spinal tap
in 1978
and then you know the the documentary we
often don't realize how late it was in
the game it's 1984 you know
and it's ostensibly following the band
on a 1982 1982 concert tour to promote
the new album smell the glove which
is a total backfire everything falls
apart
you know you couldn't pick
uh
a better like
representation of all the things that
can go wrong with a metal band at the
time
and then they appear on snl and that's
where i first saw him you know uh they
they came on to snl
and they played christmas with the devil
and i think big bottom
and i thought they were a real band
you know i that's the first time i saw i
saw him do christmas with the devil and
i was a little scared i didn't you know
i didn't know it was supposed to be
funny so yeah it was kind of disturbing
that you know that
but you know that's how close to the
truth they were i guess because well you
know there's people that saw spinal tap
that thought it was a real band
well and and this is where we get to the
interesting sort of like
where do we draw the line because i mean
they actually did produce records
and the stuff that they do is metal i
think
you know
it's a little bit more more in some
respects kind of cruder
um it's not like you know your typical
80s metal it's not judas priest it's not
rat it's not you know
it's not the slick produced stuff of the
time it's more like the stuff in the 70s
i would say
um
yeah
but they
yeah i mean they have they have an album
um
actually several albums uh and then they
did follow-up albums break like the wind
in 1992 back and forth
yeah
they actually went on tour they played
here at a venue called great woods which
is a 10 000 seater
i didn't go because you know
they had all the antics on stage they
had you know and they put a dvd or a vhs
out of that tour which i have
that's awesome
and
so you're right i mean they were
actually playing their instruments
um well you know if you go if you go to
like um
wikipedia they have a discography and
the discography includes like their
actual albums and then all these made-up
albums that never existed so they
created a whole backstory for the band
and you know what what are the things
that that happen in it it's you know
there's the
jokes about uh smuggling in vegetables
in your spandex
um you mentioned like the bassist who
doesn't know
where his instrument is they lose
everything right
yeah
i mean um
well
the thing about that movie
is
i don't know how many times you've seen
it but i always
get a joke
you know i've seen it hundreds of times
you see something that you missed before
you know what i missed for years not to
interrupt your flow no go ahead
so remember the lobby mark i'm assuming
you you know the scene
and they bump into the guy that played
um
uh johnny fever on wkrp
and so there's a super famous guy they
bumped into and they're like you know oh
hey me and i'm the manager of spinal tap
he's like liam
you know it's like so this big mega star
it's like i don't know we're playing the
enormo dome and okay well i'd like to
talk to we're going to wait in the lobby
for the limo
so then they leave and and david said
hum is like wanka and they're like
making fun of them and here's the thing
i missed and it sounds silly goes we had
to he goes back in this the festival of
1979 we had to apologize for his set
with our set when we came out on stage
they were still booing his set
[Laughter]
well i mean part of what that
illustrates is the uh the shifting in in
bands that was going on you know you've
got these famous stories of like
um
so in the 1980s dawkin and crocus toured
together and doc and blew crocus away
you know and that was kind of like
crocus was going downhill after that but
there were earlier things like um
kiss touring with black sabbath and
black sabbath being all strung out and
kissed being high energy at the time and
kiss upstaging them and then kiss got
upstaged by
van halen right and so you get you get a
lot of these sort of like somebody's
going up somebody's going down things
um what other elements i mean the um
uh
girlfriend coming in oh god yeah over
management i mean
on retrospect you know so it's natural
to think okay um yoko and and john
lennon but
um
this is also the time that was happening
with uh sharon osborne and ozzy osbourne
exactly you know exactly right but we
could also think in retrospect about um
wolf hoffman with accept who got his
bandmates to sign over all their rights
to him
his girlfriend was man now wife was
managing except at the time that's why
wolf hoffman can tour right now with
nobody else from the band um
even even peter baltis has gotten sick
of him and uh can claim the accept title
you know
well you know you made me think last
episode we were talking you s uh we were
talking about the ozzie er of the
ultimate sin
knows all sharon's doing but remember in
spinal tap
um
oh god why do i forget her name well the
girlfriend handed out like the zodiac
symbols that they're all going to dress
as oh right right yeah
yeah sharon osbourne picked all the
costumes for the ultimate set and they
are just atrocious oh yeah
um that aspect um
you know uh well you know the the
hobnobbing like at the the party when
it's like you know bobby fleckman you
guys don't talk so much let me do the
talking you know and then you know oh
look we just got word kmart and caldor
refused to carry the album you know
because just because of the cover and
you know them being confused there's a
fine line between clever and stupid
yeah i mean
the the album issues so
a lot of people say that's a reference
to um the scorpion's virgin killer right
yeah which you can't even find on
apple music um it's it's like out of
circulation
weirdly enough right
um yeah most most of the scorpions
discography from that early period is
available won't dove fly to the rainbow
um in trance um
oh what's the other one from the leah
john roth era
well virgin killer is the one that's not
not out there and so
you know they they actually did replace
the album cover
i think in the us
um but you still can't find it on itunes
you know
oh that's interesting yeah
um i mean what else there's we mentioned
the stonehenge thing you know
all the different things that go wrong
on stage
uh are being depicted there
um the food backstage like the catering
you know
that's that is that's exactly what you
know bands get and you know him you know
having his uh
nigel having his whole fit about and
who's in here nobody and he's who's in
here a little a little guy so it's a
complete catastrophe and you know he's
like hey i don't want to ruin your
performance he's like no i'm a
professional i'll rise above it you know
it's just like the hissy fit over like
nothing it's just a stupid college these
people don't know how to treat royalty
you know it's like
like a kind of diva issue and no no no
no i'm gonna overcome this i'm gonna do
a good show um
i mean
oh go ahead well another thing that
became a trope and
you know it's not as if it didn't exist
before
is being big in japan like totally
failing in the uk in europe in america
canada
but being big in japan you know
that's where they got their their latest
drummer joe mama besser
the drummer thing too yeah right uh
didn't they had a drummer who blew up i
think
spontaneously combusted right right like
there's a little globby left on the seat
you know and it's it's not very much
well known that thousands of people
spontaneously combust a year
um but
the album reviews remember the album
review scene right yeah yeah like
they're swimming in a sea of sexual
retardation and derek smalls goes with
this point he goes oh that's a good one
that's a good one
now they actually did research for this
um you know for example um
rob reiner he he talks about going to a
judas priest show and he hated it
he absolutely hated and he then look
look at these stupid people you know and
the band was too loud and stuff like
that but he he did go to like do some
some you know
research on on what it was like to be in
a metal show
um harry shearer actually traveled with
sax
i didn't know that yeah now that's i
mean and he traveled with saxon at the
right time you know saxon is still
putting out great records and touring
but you know they're like biff byford i
think is is in his 70s um there's still
some other original members in the band
and so they're not like you know
engaging in rock and roll debauchery or
anything like that but you know circa
1982 1983
who knows leather right
yeah yeah yeah well i'm crusader too i
think right yep
a strong arm of the law was out by then
as well so they they were riding pretty
high
and you know they i think they were a
fairly prototypical metal band you know
um so it's not as if these guys just
like watched a bunch of tv shows or
videos and they're like ah let's let's
screw with these people they actually
did some research well not only that but
since they they're able to play rock and
roll on their instruments they they've
got some influence and they've probably
owned the records and they've you know
maybe you know and it's funny i mean
they got the the beatles thing
uh perfect with um and then uh
uh what was the uh then the fl listen to
the flower people i mean they got that
when they did their first um
their first stuff uh i think that was
kind of making fun of like
yeah yeah i think that might have been
making fun a little bit of like uriah
heap and uh deep purple whose early work
is it's not as edgy it's not as metally
you know it's a little bit more
it's not quite flower power stuff but
it's
you know
and then uh what's like the the um the
dirty water ass uh give me some money
you know what's funny about giving some
money is that's been used in a lot of
movies
really because yeah like it was in don't
tell mom the babysitter's dead
and it's okay it's actually you know it
sounds legitimate if you don't know
i mean they did a fantastic job of that
era the guitars found the drum fill
give me some
perennial yeah
but you know so you know it's funny
because
we call it a parody band but here they
here they did a tour they did legitimate
albums and they they're getting sync
royalties on whoever wrote well
christopher guest is the one that wrote
those songs so he's when they use it in
movies he's getting paychecks that's
kind of funny right so it's it's a it's
a perotic song but it has real life
effects like a actual song would right
well yeah because it is an actual song
yeah it's an actual tune and i'd be
curious to see
if i've i've watched movies and said to
everybody hey this is from a joke band
you know yeah i mean you know it's like
um
and and the lyrics are always you know
pretty silly in some way
um
uh
hell hole and
you know
big bottom you know
exactly and um well you know at the end
we've all seen the interviews again when
they're rolling the credits
you know and um
it's like you know derek smalls has his
pipe in in in rob reiner's like so
you're working on new mushrooms yeah the
new stuff
is you know really great the old stuff
we did was very you know rubbish the new
stuff we're doing like sex farm
[Laughter]
and then rob reiner kind of like they
have this thing it's like it's about sex
on a far no it's a mature look at sex on
a farm you know
the old stuff was rubbish i think if i
remember right there was an actual video
for that or it might have been for
hellhole
and it was at the very end of it was
like a bonus um clip at the end of the
vhs cassette
and it was an actual video
they did an actual music video yeah um
but i love that it's like our early
stuff was rubbish this is the real
that's kind of you know a pumpkin like
you know
these metal a lot of these metal bands
it's it's it's uh
do they think this is so insightful and
are they like so deep about their lyrics
um
but you know the end part
with the interviews is hysterical
yeah it's you know of course they're
they're improv comedians
um so they used to go do you see them on
rock line when they were in character it
was like
you
and they fielded calls and bam quick i
mean they're pretty amazing
yeah you know but um the characters
themselves so
spinal tap has become a thing until
i mean i wonder if like what if that
movie flop
you know
what if what would have happened in
terms of parody stuff i i think probably
there there would still be
some kinds of parody going on but maybe
it wouldn't have been as
elaborate and maybe comedians wouldn't
have gotten into it so this is a good
good um segue into some of the
other bands
um you know for example witch taint
which is a contemporary
two-person metal band the members are
lance the king of black metal and
matthias backwards
they do actually have an album sons of
midwestern darkness
they bill themselves as the most extreme
norwegian black metal band from indiana
of all time
and they've got some really great i mean
you can find them on youtube primarily i
mean you could also buy the album if you
wanted to but you watching the videos i
think is integral to it so they have
like are you ready to in parentheses
black metal um they have death to death
metal they're they're like you know
going back and forth about these genres
and then the funniest one is called
um ready for
love but it's spelled lv
and it's it's
sort of a take on you know the sort of
smooth jazzy kind of love song except
these guys are in face paint
and um you know they've got like a
beautiful model who's like you know
blowing them kisses and stuff like that
and then the the the joke is they don't
want to have love they don't want to
have sex they don't want to do any of
that sort of stuff they want to play
their their metal instead
and it started out as
black metal dialogues which became a
two-man stage show
and then it turned into a band and
here's so here's an interview from
one of them
once phil and i started doing the live
show we gradually began adding more
music by the time we did the walk-in
festival in 2018 we noticed how confused
confused at least half the crowd was
when they saw two guys in corpse paint
just reading from their laptops in a
field of germany but whenever we'd play
the three or four witch taint songs we'd
add to the show the place would go nuts
we did shows every day at walken and i
think after the second day we decided
we'd turn witch taint into an actual
band and make an album and all that and
i said you know as i was watching their
videos
i was thinking
these guys are like the black metal
version of insane clown posse right you
guys okay there you go yeah they both
sing one of them plays the guitar they
have all these skits that they're doing
before it
and you know they're not they're not
particularly um good-looking guys you
know one of them's kind of kind of
chubby and they come up with all this
funny stuff you know so those are
comedians right those
now would they exist without spinal tap
um you know i i don't know you know
maybe spinal tip got things going but 20
years later well more than 20 years
later right
bands can can emerge out of comedy
situations
um
max sabbath you know is essentially a
comedy band and we talked about them a
little bit before and then um what's the
one jack black's band
oh tenacious d right yeah
two comedians
uh it's coming out in part of uh i think
mr show
um
yeah and then they eventually they get a
movie that they do they've got albums um
and
they get deal in their video
yeah well lots
they have a lot of uh people that who
liked them in the metal scene
and it's it to go back to mark's thing
about like you know the spiritedness
right they're not making fun of things
to tear them down
it's in a way an homage right how do how
do comedians
um do metal well it's gotta it's got to
be funny stuff i guess right
yeah and you never saw it as well you
know what's the one um
where uh well actually dio had tenacious
d in in the video of push
okay
and so
they're they're playing um heaven and
hell but changing the words
and deal walks down and puts money in
the hat and says now play some tenacious
d
you know
and they're like whoa you know the king
is here you know it's dead yeah
and then didn't they do a song um about
dio
you you're all done hand over the hand
over the cape and the scepter two like
they had this joke song about but they
were like the new they were taking over
from do like they were the inheritors
right
yeah yeah
and that's you know that's out of pure
love i think
i think you're right and you know when
we talk about steel panther we've
brought up before
it's also coming out of a similar
kind of love for the music because they
start playing in la on the sunset strip
in the early 2000s and they're first
called metal shop and then they're
called metal school s-k-o-o-l
um so this is before they're actually
steel panther and they would play on
monday nights at the viper room and then
the key club and they played covers they
were doing hair metal stuff you know so
motley crew and rat and docking and
stuff like that and then they had an ep
in 2003 called whole patrol
where they do that sort of stuff and
then they they start getting some
television things they're in a discover
card advertisement as danger kitty um
they're on the drew carey show as
themselves and then at the gene simmons
roast
metal school played some original songs
as well as covers of kiss songs and then
in 2008 they they changed their name
they become steel panther
and they release feel the steel
there's a behind the music steel panther
in 2009 which was an itunes podcast and
it was a fake behind the music story
about this crazy band right
um
so it wasn't a real it was vh1 who did
behind the music i think right
so so this is not vh1 doing it this is
this is them having somebody else do it
and then they you know they become a
touring band and they've got you know um
i mean you you think about the names of
the albums balls out
all you can eat lower the bar
have you ever a good one
heavy metal rules is 2019.
and they they've gone through a lot of
people but their their current lineup is
uh uh you know michael starr
satchel styx zadina and uh ricky thrash
so those are some cool names you know
this this is another part of parody i
guess it's having stage names you know
yeah um
the thing about steel panther though
there's two things i want to point out
there
each of them are from legitimate la
metal bands that's right yeah yeah and
that's the first thing and the second
thing um
that i don't get which surprises me all
my metalhead friends like including the
musicians that are metal guitar players
and metal drummers yeah are so into this
band they always buy a ticket to see
them when they're in town
um and for me i you know i think it's
kind of funny but um
i don't know if i'm gonna pay a ticket
to see a show i mean
it you know to me it's kind of like you
know satchels like the nigel tuffle
satchels
doesn't get it you know so you know he's
to me and this is only my opinion
they're just kind of emulating spinal
tap i mean
there may be spinal tap did pave the way
for their them as a possibility right
but yeah i guess if i was in a band and
then i was just going to be clueless in
the way that nigel tuftel was that's
already been done
so um you know i guess they're a joke
band in a sense but serious musicians
yep the serious following
you know
we saw them opening for judah's priest
in
was it jersey i think
years and years and years ago
and it was i mean it was it was a great
show they have a very high energy yeah
they actually brought a mom and her kid
up on stage because there was there was
a mom there with like her i don't know
maybe 15 year old kid and they're like
what's that kid doing here this is
pretty raunchy you know and so they were
like come on up here and they brought
her up and they're like
do you understand the kind of lyrics
that we have is this a good influence on
your son
it was really quite quite funny you know
that's well so
i have i had this student at berkeley
and he's just one of those people that
uh just cool things happen to all the
time like
break and he and he came back once and
he's like oh i met uh adrian smith like
in his favorite band as iron maiden wow
and then
on another break
he's from california he went to see
steel panther and all of a sudden i see
they dragged him up on stage
and sasha goes what do you think you're
better than me
and my student was laughing he goes well
fine take my guitar what do you want to
play he goes you guys know the trooper
he goes yeah so satchel sits there and
like stares at my student while the band
plays the trooper
and uh and so like my student got to
play like a tune with steel panther so
uh i i thought that was great and of
course he's a huge steel panther fan and
a huge maiden fan and you know he came
back he's like i got to play with steel
panther so yeah something else arc has a
good question here do you think the
parody of these bands would be less
effective if they didn't have
music chops to back it up would it come
across as less sincere more gimmicky i
think that's a perfect question for you
scott because
you know i'm i'm i'm an amateur musician
at best you're you're a professional
musician
um and we both you know we're
we both know these bands but what do you
think if steel panther couldn't play
their instruments as well could their
their comedy be as effective well spinal
tap they can't really play their
instruments that well they could play
good enough
um
so
yeah yeah but
they play a good enough um and to play
the tunes to write the tunes
um
so i don't think you have to be on the
level of steel panther i think you need
the content you know i think
you know if you can't play at all then
you know
you're you're parodying the wrong
thing or the wrong yeah you know if you
think about what you're actually
parodying um
i mean you could do a drum solo as a
drummer how do you make that periodic
right
you could screw around on your base and
now maybe you got a little bit more room
you know you
make the strings all floppy or something
or yeah i don't know
the double bass thing that they did have
in spinal tap right is making fun of the
guitar uh double guitar thing
but your lyric content right that's what
you're saying that's where you can
really show that it's it's being goofy
well i think in spinal taps case if you
look at the um
it was perfect so uh
you know nigel says i'm known for my
solos
and like shooting darts like rubber
darts at the strings yeah like
hitting open strings with his foot while
he's just playing and then my favorite
is he takes a violin and starts doing
this to the strings and he stops and he
tunes the violin a little bit
so i mean in that case it kind of shows
how ridiculous the unaccompanied solo
was and yeah so so guitar okay you can
do a bit with that and you can certainly
do a lot with vocals
could you have like a really goofy thing
with a keyboardist
uh sure i mean i mean i guess spinal tap
kind of did like that organ
um sometimes i don't know if his on
purpose was mixed a little too loud and
it was like a little intrusive
everything and
um
or and sometimes you just hear like
wrong notes played or you know
yeah
so uh but like
it's the three main guys so i guess
everybody else is kind of like
uh we're really part of the band
especially
you know so a couple other bands that
come to mind in terms of like doing
really
periodic you know satirical kind of
stuff that have good chops
um
[Music]
you know there's there's this band uh
nanowar of steel obviously making fun of
man of war taking the manowar thing a
little bit further
they're pretty good you know in terms of
i've listened to a few of their tracks
um
they have all these these funny albums
you know they began with triumph of true
medal of steel
uh in 2003 and then they have other
bands play nanowar gay into gay pride
ride the night at the opera stairway to
valhalla and their latest is italian
folk medal
and you know these are obviously like
playing off of man-o-war
stuff as well as uh other other bands
being kind of over the top and with the
sexuality thing too right you know some
some metal is like hyper masculine these
guys are kind of playing around with
that i also think um if people haven't
heard of them betty blowtorch um
you know
they they've been gone for a long time
um in part because they're they're um
singer and bassist uh bianca um
wound up um dying you know in a car
crash um
but they you know they've got some
pretty raunchy stuff there they've got
some definite music chops they were
quite good um two of their members went
on to be in all female tribute bands
black sabbath black sabbath
black sabbath and and hell's bells
um so you know
those are those were quite good um mark
smith says um manowar is rich for parody
they legit have songs that make me
cringe yeah and this we were talking
about this earlier right
some of it is is it's hard to tell
whether it's supposed to be parody or
not you know
um
yeah i guess yeah some of the um
like we were saying we talked about gore
in the same sentence
but you know if if somebody takes
themselves way too seriously and they're
out there
um it's right for thinking it's parody
but you know um
i guess the test would be to ask them
are you joking around and if they get
kicked off at you and they're like no
we're not joking around then you know
you know that they're being serious
about it and you've hurt their feelings
by
treating them as if they're parody but
then there's bands what was the one
album in the mid 80s that gene simmons
produced um the album was called the
right to rock
and who was the band oh i don't remember
yeah um mark
help me out here um
1985 and
gene simmons was making tv appearances
on day shows with the singer the
promoting album
but anyways the right to rock i mean
even at the time like we laughed it's
like
you know
um
got it well i mean deal
keel that's that's who it is there were
a lot of um
song titles album titles
that you know in in by the time we get
to the 80s where you're like come on you
know
uh this this is just um
you you're not exercising any
imagination at this point in in you know
the the metal scene and maybe some of
the people doing that you know they they
actually
they didn't have that much imagination
i mean how many how many times can you
have the same
trope being used you know
and i think you know
growing up
in that era
you and i um
you know we were legitimately into a lot
of this music so i guess we would be
good
good uh barometers or good uh
you know if something came out it's like
okay come on you know you know if if we
did it because we were already into the
genre if it got if some producer said
you know
you know like twisted sister got away
with it with like i want to rock and
we're not going to take it and those
were funny videos you know yeah yeah um
but you know they were still kind of
anthems but then when you had people
kind of like doing the same thing but
not with the same
uh clout or they came too late to the
game
um
well they're sort of like the guy
who
wanders into a conversation at a party
and he's heard the other people i don't
know like maybe
referencing a movie and they said the
catch line from the movie and then two
minutes later he's saying it and now
it's not funny anymore right right
or clever you know
it you know it's kind of it
we have to
well i think we even um
uh even kiss like they blew it what was
the one god big rock and roll for you
uh that horrible like um you know it was
like this anthem they didn't what was it
um
the album after hot in the shade revenge
it's funny because that's included on a
lot of kiss anthologies
oh god it was a big video at the time
and i just remember going okay come on
you know
i'm a huge kiss fan but this is awful
you know but you know that was just me i
i don't know if money put that on the
air
that could be yeah
you know another band that's kind of
interesting and i've listened to a bit
of their stuff i don't know if you've
listened to them at all is ale storm and
they are
a pirate metal band and i know one of
the things we could ask about pirate
metal is is this all parody to begin
with or should this be looked at as
serious because i mean how can you be a
pirate in the the present day i mean i
know there's a pirate political party
out there in some scandinavian countries
we actually had a pirate candidate here
in milwaukee a long time ago
um but it's you know are you really a
pirate these days
um
and i know they tell me this
about being a pirate or no pirate medal
okay
uh what did they say well you know i
said is this a joke the pirate medal of
course this has got this was a while ago
and they said no
it's a genre it's a legitimate genre
well and mark brings up running wild and
so running wild is sort of the
progenitor of it because they have under
jolly roger and this is pretty old 1987
right and when they were asked about
that their people said did you intend to
create a pirate metal album and they're
like no it just kind of fit the themes
and it turned out that way and then from
that point we
kept on pirating on so so it is a genre
um
[Music]
and
so this person felt that it's like a
serious genre these are people who are
creating legitimate pirate songs
right right well yeah i mean i guess
it's like a it's uh there's legitimate
pirate bands i guess and i didn't i know
it
genre it is a genre yeah it includes
like sea shanties and sometimes having
like a concertina playing things like
that yeah
yeah
uh
the dictators oh my gosh
going going back there
yeah um
i mean mark points this out sub-genre
proliferation and contemporary metal is
kind of nuts and
that lends itself to you know like so
we're you know i'm doing you know
folk death you know we'll add in a
couple more qualifiers metal at a
certain point you got to be like what
are you doing
how is this
this this tiny little micro niche what
is what is going on here you know
and they're self uh i'm finding
that a lot of these people are are self
titling their genre
oh so so here's some from
mark nintendo
i have no idea what nintendo core is but
and i and scott you've told me before
about math metal porno grind i don't
know that one either um nintendo core
there was a thing in the early 90s
even at um
even a lot of my students who were like
doing their
uh projects or whatever they would do um
they would do covers of nintendo games
you know like they replayed yeah you
know and they would play it on guitar
and they would play they would play it
on guitar and then that became a thing
and then um
now
nintendo core led to a lot of
guitarists wanting to make guitar music
for
video games now but it's we call it it's
very um
it's very stiff on the beat playing it
sounds like a computer like
there's no
uh i don't mean this derogatory there's
no real real soul in the plane it's
designed to play like the old nintendo
64. yeah
and and so um it could be heavy and loud
but just not really
rock in my sense
but like you know it's a sub genre but
you know i mean i've heard
like three sentence definitely like what
do you consider that you know you just
showed me this what do you consider it i
would consider it you know prague maybe
okay well yeah maybe maybe there's a
broad sense in which like prague could
be the
category that a lot of these things like
math rock could could fit under although
i mean there is something that we could
call like classic prague metal you know
i mean obviously rush and you know yes
yeah well and and um
you know there were some key prague
bands coming out in the
80s
um
that would that would fit in with that i
mean and some bands did prague phases i
mean you could say somewhere in time is
kind of a prague pragee album right
compared to
others um
[Music]
yeah i mean they had their um
there's a lot of like long guitar
sections in that one that which i like
like loneliness of long distance runner
yeah
um but you know
iron maiden's a really interesting one
because i remember when spinal tap came
out i had my live after death yeah yes
like we
we i'm sure all of us did right uh that
are metal heads and i would have it
running at my house all the time and my
friends would come over and just shake
their head and go these guys are remind
me of spinal tap and i get really mad at
them you know
yeah but like you know i i guess looking
back i could see how they would say that
but i'm like you're wearing spandex all
the time you know yeah they've got the
like the the eddy coming out and like
the
and um i used to get really mad about
that that you know they were they were
kind of my friends would say that you
know pretty much iron maiden is a parody
band is ridiculous
you know and um i didn't think they were
ridiculous at all i you know i was a
huge fan although i did spinal tap was
yeah
yeah you know when i was that age iron
maiden was my favorite band yeah
certainly one of mine we talked about
the trooper last time yeah
there is one other band before we run
out of time that i i think we absolutely
have to talk about and that is the
fictional band death clock which exists
as cartoon characters but has made
albums and gone on tour
uh with brendan smalls you know
singing and stuff like that and this is
you know in the show met apocalypse
which unfortunately was cancelled by
adult swim in 2015
and you know it's it's it's certainly
parody it's like parody on top of parody
both of like the band and the kind of
things that they're singing like you
know they've got a band i ejaculate fire
and also like the entire lifestyle i
mean it's it's this i mean it's it's
crazy because for those who don't know
it and might be watching this um death
clock becomes a international sensation
not just musically but economically uh
militarily you know they fight trolls uh
they
you know there's a secret cabal of
people that are obsessed with death
clock and are charting their their every
move they there's you know like an
entire industry surrounding
death clock and so you got these five
crazy characters nathan explosion who
obviously is supposed to be like one
dancing right um right
swisskar svigelf who's this you know
you know hoity toity
uh perfect guitar player who who's
always right you know sort of banking on
his fellow guitar player uh poor toki
wartooth and then you've got pickles
who's also from wisconsin um
and he's got the wisconsin accent the up
up north the otter hay accent you know
not not the down here and right
milwaukee land accent and then last and
definitely last because he's least is
william murder face yeah the poor
bassist who's always feeling inferior
you know and he gets like left behind in
places
and there's other i mean my favorite
other character in that is dr roxo the
rock and roll roll clown who is clearly
david lee roth right
um but you also have already
you know david lee roth i mean
yeah i mean david lee roth is kind of a
parody of himself uh and deliberately so
when when van halen was taking off but
you also have snakes and barrels pickles
for his band right which could be guns
and roses or could be motley crew or any
of these hair bands right
and
the the potential for
developing these characters and playing
you know off of them in a tv show as
opposed to a movie like so spinal tap's
a movie great movie a lot accomplished
there
when you've got a tv show that runs for
season after season with you know dozens
of episodes you can do so much more
in exploring this erotic stuff and they
even you know they at the end of
episodes they're often playing a song
you know uh that has a music video so
there's tons and tons of content out
there
oh right the joke about making an album
for fish yeah there's there's all sorts
of things about the recording process
like they're going to go underneath the
sea
and what record on water i think right
was the idea
well
um
with metal aqualypse i don't know um
i don't know why this scene stays in my
head it was william murderface
and the guitarist and they were lost in
some jungle okay and they were just
walking
now under the circumstances you know i
would be freaking out like there's no
help anywhere it's like you know
um and they're walking and all
william murder faces complaining about
the guitarist's tone from the night
before and they were having an argument
about the guitar tone it was a little
buzzy it was you know it's real it was
real tinny and you know this
conversation they're having completely
unaware of like you know there's like
snakes in the trees and they're like you
know
it's like
they could die at any second and they're
fighting over the you know the guitarist
tone i just i don't know why that that's
like the number one scene in my head but
because it's well william murderface
last and least but
i love that character you know
[Laughter]
yeah i mean
it's a great mix i mean they managed to
capture and maybe this is something that
could only happen like later down the
line so spinal tap is this funny
experimental thing they're throwing all
these cool things in like oh the amp
goes up to 11 right and all these things
that we we remember
but
in a way
they hadn't gotten the formula
completely down
you know by the time that you've got
meta metapocalypse
and people pitching these things you
know decades have passed so they can
they can do it in a more methodical way
you know well so it could become a
series you know episode episode
well i don't think you could have done
that either in the 80s i mean how would
you have gotten yeah you would have
gotten like one of the main
uh
tv networks to sign off on it i mean
maybe it could have happened in the bbc
right but i don't think it could have
happened in our our you know abc nbc
cbs i don't even think fox would have
been willing to do that they were
willing to have you know musicians
appear on shows like anthrax show up on
uh
married with children the way that
motorhead had on the young ones
um
so maybe the bbc would have greenlighted
something like that but
i can't see american stuff doing it and
mtv and vh1 could have done stuff like
that but they would be making fun of
their own
people so maybe they'd view that as
undercutting themselves so you know mark
brings up adult swim has been important
to metal parity um yeah i mean adult
swim
so you know metapocalypse we talked
about aqua teen hunger force uh space
ghost coast-to-coast nice to watch that
yeah
i mean
adult swim was so experimental
um
they there's a lot of shows on it that
are not particularly great but they
appeal to somebody right and they tried
so many interesting things out um
maybe it took something like that
uh mr p
mr pickles is another
metal based one mr pickles if people
haven't seen it is about a
a satanic dog who may in fact be the
devil himself named mr pickles and he's
named mr pickles because his treat is
you know when he's a good dog timmy will
give him a pickle which he enjoys um
on an unusual dog and grandpa in the
family has figured out that mr pickles
is evil
um and he's always you know talking
about that mr pickles gets into all
sorts of adventures and he runs into
other evil doers and he usually does
them in you know sometimes turning them
into [ __ ] slaves sometimes just
disemboweling them you know and and the
the cutest thing about it is mr pickles
loves his his boy you know um who's
totally clueless
right exactly
so
yeah so mr pickles i mean mr pickles
begins with a a growling metal sawing
you know
that's the theme song you need that
yeah
so yeah maybe adult swim has been the
best home for this i mean we do have we
mentioned some of these other bands
you know like tenacious d or um you know
like mac sabbath or witch taint there's
there's certainly a
metal ecology out there that allows for
these sorts of
these sorts of new growths to take place
you know there's there's enough support
for it one last thing i think that um
you just made me think of
mtv did
accept uh a parody show but at an
interesting time beavis and butthead
came in the early 90s
when when they wanted to bring the new
brand of grunge in and get rid of what
they became
we never said the word hair metal
mtv coin yeah
the mtv coined that phrase to make fun
of it beavis and butt head comes in to
make fun of all the hair metal and to
bring in their new brand of grunge right
so it's interesting yeah yeah uh
metallica can stay
um but you know all these other bands
like winger we're gonna make fun of hair
metal and here's our news called grunge
they wouldn't have let beavis and bud
head happen in 87.
yeah that makes that makes a lot of
sense actually um
so interesting how parity is used there
i would say as a marketing tech i mean
you've got pretty high end marketers
marketing people there i mean they're
not just throwing they're not just
spitballing over there i mean you know
the grunge movement came in and
we might we might even generate a new
conspiracy theory here
well it's not i don't even think it's i
mean i think it's uh
is it a tested that like the mtv
actually like do we know about any
this stuff from like memos or
interviews or stuff like that well i
think this timing speaks for itself
because they would never accept a show
in 87 that made fun of the videos and
having these two guys that every thought
was cool and you know the animation was
crappy remember we were getting into
movies like clerks which were like you
know we were getting into you know
everything's reactionary so we could
call the 1980s baroque
a very
ornamented very you know and then we
were going to grunge where everybody
were doc martens and there was one style
doc martens and and plaid and
um
you know i think uh
the quality of the the cartoon would
have never been accepted in the 80s and
we of course mt would say we're not
making fun of the artists we're playing
but they do want to you know i mean it
just that's right yeah yeah i think
you're right it just makes sense that
it's like okay it's the 90s now and um
you know get with the program with the
program yeah and um it worked you know
and uh it worked and then of course you
know they they stole everything from
mike judge so he had to do king of the
hill and
once you know he wasn't of use they kind
of screwed him over
oh did that
yeah he doesn't have the rights to be
this but he doesn't make a dime from it
wow
so that's why he started to get a hill
okay
and that didn't appear on mtv so
yeah yeah
but it's just it's interesting i just i
think um the parody there
you know
here's these dumb kids but you know
everybody was like yeah down with winger
because the dork is wearing the hair
metal shirt and you know
down with this and i mean that's what
happened whether it i think it was by
design or i think it was the timing for
it at least maybe it wasn't so there's
two possibilities one is it's by design
the others it's part of like the
zeitgeist and it just art imitates life
we say right
but it was a good yeah it worked as a
good advertising
yeah you know it brought in it brought
the mindset of the kids in which were us
you know
you know
yeah yeah
but yeah
well this is a good place i think to
wrap up we covered a lot of ground in
terms of perotic metal elements there's
a lot of great metal that is parody i do
want to mention one thing that scott and
i had talked about because we did a
little research on this
you know one of the kings of parody
music is weirdo yankovic and so i
thought well did he do any like you know
perotic metal songs and the answer is no
i actually went through his whole
catalog
and he hits almost every other popular
genre of music but for some reason
and i don't know why this is the case he
he just didn't do any heavy metal songs
that were parody edit is is not a metal
song that's michael jackson um although
they're in the eddie van halen part
where the guitarist explodes at the end
right exactly yeah yeah i mean eddie van
halen did a couple um
things where he he'd like lend out his
talents to different people he also
played on wendy o williams
um
bump and grind you know um so that
doesn't by itself make it metal um but
that would be the closest connection i
guess you could say to metal right and
the thing he started out with just his
accordion remember another one right
plus dr demento
i mean it's funny because if you think
about metal adjacent genres like grunge
um yankovic did grunge stuff he just
didn't do any classic metal stuff and
it's right into the nirvana one yeah i i
don't know why he uh stayed away from it
but that just seems to be the what what
ended up happening so
anything else that you want to say scott
before we uh
head out
no i think uh we covered a lot of stuff
that was actually a lot of fun yeah yeah
well parody should be right ideally
we shouldn't be very serious oh is this
parody one parody two you know it should
be
enjoyable so
yeah thanks thanks mark for joining us
yeah mark great to see you thanks thomas
couple other people came in and out as
as we went but didn't have any any
comments uh so
but yeah good session
all right so until next month
see you everybody
take care
you